un mois de tournée déjà et un arrêt par
guyancourt les wampas mené depuis 34 ans
par didier wampas un rocker authentique
étaient présents à la batterie pour
présenter leur dernier album evangelisti
c'était un peu une légende des joutes et
l'a gagné 5,6 fois c'est le bonhomme il
fait 200 kilos et je tanne visiblement
voulais pas qu'ils gagnent on l'a
éliminée injustement j'étais là quand
j'ai vu ça c'est la révolte et 6/10
appelé l'album evangelisti pour le
venger
evangelisti ben je rencontre plein de
choses plein de petites anecdotes plein
de petites tranches de vivre là n'a pas
de grands messages jamais de gros
message c'est plein de petits messages
qu'il faut un grand message peut-être je
ne sais pas sortie le 12 février
évangéliste tissée l'histoire d'un
groupe dispersés aux quatre coins de la
france
un groupe hors du temps qui s'attaque
aux sujets quotidiens
je crie pas trop j'aimerais pas trop le
fois je me dis deux idées sur des
carnets mais pas grand chose et ce en
studio que j'écris presque toujours tout
achever les chansons d'abord les hôtes
bio nomades à la matière est la
négritude dieu et après je vais il faut
faire des maîtres des paroles et ceci en
studio j'ai des idées ou pas d'approuver
des paroles là dessus pas de limite ou
non aucune nostalgie à landser n'y a pas
de nostalgie déjà on essaie de faire
apprendre tous les nouveaux morceaux
bien les jouer sur scène essayer ces
nouveaux tous les soirs sans attache le
groupe parcourt le pays pour assouvir sa
passion de la musique rock est les
wampas ne compte pas s'arrêter en si bon
chemin et poursuivront leur tournée
jusqu'à l'été
non